automakers are again projected to double  spending on electric vehicles by 2030. I  think that this is a very good thing the  criticisms that the anti-electric  vehicle right has about electric  vehicles are all issues that can be  dealt with what do you do with the  batteries at the end of their life  Engineers are going to figure that out  that's a temporary problem what about  limited range or slow charging times  that's already been proved upon and been  improved upon dramatically over the last  two years and five years and ten years  and it will continue to improve nothing  you can do about a gas powered or  diesel-powered internal combustion  engine will change the fact  that you are burning a resource that is  limited  and spewing pollution into the air  nothing will change that whereas the  issues with electric vehicles can and I  am sure will be solved